okay now there's lots of fun bits to
countersue shape functions I'm gonna try
and give us a review of how to integrate
not any of the inverse functions yet
we're just to the regular ones I've got
temp that I want to go through okay so
in each case what we're gonna do is I'm
going to show you the result which leads
to the integral so it might be the
derivative result or a particular
identity that might help us with it so
there's ten of them before we get to B
inverse stuff okay so you ready we'll
start with the simple ones fine
differentiate sine get close right there
for read the ground-breaking I do it the
integral of cos if we're thinking
indefinite integrals is sine X plus a
constant
okay mr. Foster good and starts nice and
gently
ah let's move along if I differentiate
cosine you have to watch for the change
of sign right get a change right so
therefore if you integrate something
you're just going to get now remember
this negative here it can be one out the
front and one outside they'd refer to
make it positive okay so what that's
gonna make you one is okay
the Duda 10 is second squared therefore
the integral of second squared with
respect to X is 10
all right now I've got sign a close and
where they come from what if I integrate
10
I was integrating Constitution this
integrate sine gives you this the
interval of 10 is little different
because it's it's chain rule right it's
reverse chain rule because it's what you
get is a log function if you remember so
which log functions we differentiate to
get 10 log of the chain rule for log
functions right is going to be whatever
this thing is in here it's if it's f
rights f - f that's what the chamber is
going in the poet's direction okay
so if I let's sign up cos side of the
cause I was signed to be my F - right so
therefore this is my so log of cos x you
remember it doesn't quite give you ten
what does it give you instead because f
- f - here is a negative sign right so
I'm actually getting it negative sign
therefore if I'm integrating can we lose
vector X okay cuz you got your negative
again it's the same thing we have
because okay so I want to get negative
lon okay
all right inside crosstab what I'm
missing okay
of course reciprocal functions yeah so
five let's let's do it at the table a
sign constan okay so the reciprocal of
sine is cosine
what was the dreary to your midmark we
have the second Kosek we start with this
let me add something okay so I'm gonna
have minus cosec what do I add to go
step up quite as if you're right okay
therefore if I integrate
Kosek konnex
sorry
okay don't miss the negative sign for
Nina cursor always has the negative sign
much like on section all right next one
we've got sick and the due to the sec
again you start with that function in
the Y and something in this case you add
10 so this will be sick tan okay
so therefore when I integrate a sec tan
I'm going to get okay clot I said with
over ten rumors there you differentiate
clot this is kind of like 10 so you're
gonna get something squared this was sex
squared so down here I'm going to get Co
6-pin right negative no matter yes yeah
so therefore if I integrate per sec
Chris x squared Allah what's the
negative I'm just gonna end up with
negative okay